[MUSIC PLAYING]
MEHRAN NAZIR: Welcome
to Google Cloud Next.
My name is Mehran Nazir.
I am a product manager
with Google Cloud.
And today I'll be
speaking to you
about how you can use BigQuery
to transform your organization
into a data driven one.
I'm joined by Fabrizio
Blanco from Viant Technology.
And he'll be going
into Viant's journey
to the cloud using BigQuery.
So to kick things
off, an exercise.
Does anyone recognize
what this number means?
A hint.
It's something that you
would find in a school
anywhere in the world.
Exactly.
I heard someone in the
back saying that it's
the Dewey Decimal system.
Exactly what it is.
So let's break that
down bit by bit.
Leading 0 is a classifier
for information.
Second zero is for computing
information followed
by data processing and computer
science, networking, wide area
networks, internet, and
our final conclusion,
"Data Science on the
Google Cloud Platform,"
the title written by one of our
esteemed training team members.
Now some of you if you've
walked into a library anytime
in the past 10, 15 years, you
might have recognized that.
And for the most part,
it's a useful system.
It's a little bit subject
to human error and manual
difficulties, but it is
very important and powerful
because it allows for people
like you and me to navigate
the treasure trove
of information
that a library is,
so that it doesn't
belong to just subject domain
experts like librarians.
But we live in a
different world today.
We live in the
world of big data.
Estimates put the
Library of Congress
at anywhere between 15
to 20 terabytes of data.
For a big data
application, we can rack up
15 to 20 terabytes within days.
In some applications
sometimes hours.
And when you think about
a library that doubles
and triples in
sizes overnight, you
have a vast amount of problems.
One, scaling infrastructure.
It's not easy to find the
space to house all those books
and all that information.
And related to that is finding
the specific people that
can manage that level of data.
And to do both of those
things while controlling costs
is no trivial task.
During my time on the
Google Cloud customer team,
I worked with many customers
with various big data
implementations.
And what I realized was while
they would come to me very
often with a technology
problem, many times
it was really a change
management exercise
that was required.
And during my time, I'd
see three main archetypes
of a data driven organization.
One, you have the data driven
organization that is constantly
pulled in different directions.
This particular
team is reactive.
They don't necessarily have
the proper data infrastructure.
And they tend to be really just
a supporter of the business
intelligence organization.
The second type is one that is
fun but not very productive.
This tends to not have a
very strong relationship
with the engineering
and product team, which
allows them to have very
limited product influence
and seems to be
typically unfocused.
The best kind of data
science organization
is one where data
science are treated
as thought leaders, ones
where data contributions are
recognized and celebrated.
But most importantly, what I
want you to take away from this
is the fact that
data is democratized
and they are investing
in productivity.
Importantly, when data is
accessible and universally
available to people
within the organization,
it makes that organization
that much more tied
to data, which as we can
all agree in this room
is typically a company's
most important asset, which
transitioned to how do you do
data infrastructure with GCP.
We know that your data comes
in all shapes and sizes.
For your relational
needs, we have Cloud SQL.
We have Cloud Spanner.
For your nonrelational needs,
we have Cloud Bigtable,
Cloud Datastore for your
document database needs.
But what I'll be focusing
on primarily today
is BigQuery, the crown jewel
of our data analytics platform.
BigQuery is Google Cloud
platform's enterprise data
warehouse solution, fully
managed and serverless.
If you're used to
managing backups
and working on disaster recovery
plans with your data warehouse,
you no longer have
to worry about that,
because that is taken
care of under the hood.
If you need to run
petabyte scale data and run
queries across
multiple tables, that
can now return
within mere seconds
through a very convenient
and intuitive SQL interface.
If you need to scale up
using CPU, RAM, and memory,
no longer do you
have to manage that,
That is all again managed
under the hood from the Google
engineering team.
And more and more
what we're seeing
is our streaming
capabilities coming
to form in terms of
streaming dashboards.
But as we know that technology
is really half the problem.
The real problem is, again,
people and change management.
And when we look at
enterprise users of data,
we see them in multiple
buckets, smallest level
being deep learning researchers,
which number in the tens
of thousands, machine
learning experts, which
is in the low
millions, engineers,
which is another
order of magnitude
higher in the tens of millions,
but the largest sliver of that
are business users, business
intelligence folks, finance,
accounting, sales.
All these people are the
biggest consumers of data
yet, if we don't have
data accessible to them,
that data is no longer an asset.
So the question is, and
the question I pose to you
is how do you turn technology
from a barrier into an enabler.
With that, I'll
give it to Fabrizio
to share Viant's story.
FABRIZIO BLANCO: Thank
everyone for coming.
Let me jump to the presentation.
So what is Viant?
Viant is an advertising
technology company
that delivers the right
audiences across all inventory
formats and channels.
And it's capable of measuring
its impact online and offline.
The main piece of
technology we use to do that
is the DSP, which stands
for demand side platform.
And since I'm going to be
talking about all the data
flows into the
DSP, I may as well
give you a quick primer
about the real-time bidding
and the technology behind it.
On this picture, you see
two sides, demand side
and the supply side.
The demand side is the
advertised technology ecosystem
the advertiser used to
often spend media dollar
or to buy inventory online.
And the main piece of
technology used is a DSP.
We have one of those.
On the left side, you
have the supply side,
which is the technology
ecosystem a publisher used
to monetize their audiences
or sell inventory online.
And the main piece of
technology they use
is the SSP, which stands
for supply side platform.
The way advertisers buy
media online in real time
is via RDP protocol.
And that's how the SSP and
DSP communicate to each other.
To give an example, a
user comes to a publisher.
A publisher can be an app,
a website, a video channel,
audio channel, anything
you can imagine.
The goal of the publisher is
to maximize the revenue out
of this opportunity.
The way they do that
is by auctioning off
this opportunity to multiple
buyers at the same time.
And that's where
they use the SSP.
The SSP is connected to
multiple DSP at the same time.
DSP will just
leverage the data they
know about the user to decide if
they're willing to bid or not.
If they're willing to bid, how
much they're willing to bid.
And then if they
win the auction,
that's called an ad impression.
And the advertiser
gets to display the add
on the publisher, that happens
billions and billions of times
a day and generates
a lot of data.
Each single auction
is to be closed
within 15, 20 milliseconds.
We're talking about very complex
ad stack and a lot of data.
What does it look in terms
of data for buying DSP?
We process more than 100
billion events on a daily basis.
Those events represent more
than 100 terabytes of data.
On a second, we process
more than a million events.
And each single event does
more than 700 data points.
So when I talk about events,
I'm talking about these RTB
requests-- bid solicitation
as well as impression, clicks,
conversion, anything
you can do with ads.
And how did we manage to
do that before BigQuery?
I'm talking about before 2014.
So on the left side with
a custom ingest problem,
we ingest all this
relevant data into Hadoop.
When it was entered
into Hadoop, we
say enter the data
warehouse ecosystem.
But where there's a gray
box, you can see that--
the data warehouse ecosystem.
And the way the data
warehouse ecosystem
was managed by the
data warehouse team.
And there was a
handful of people
that were servicing the entire
organization for any data
needs.
And the way they were
processing the data
was through MapReduce, Pig,
and Hive on top of Hadoop.
And the [INAUDIBLE] that emerged
typically out of this process
will be pushed
into Netezza, which
is a physical NPP appliance you
can query via SQL interface.
And the way the business
would access the data
was through a business
intelligence tool
Tableau pointing to
these [INAUDIBLE]..
Anything outside
those [INAUDIBLE]
would need to go
through a process
of vetting polarization.
So although this picture
looks pretty nice,
it looks like everything
should be working,
the reality is it
failed to reflect
what was happening at the time.
Everything should have
been on flame and melting.
And the reason was we actually
had very hard time keeping up
with the scale of the business.
Every day more and more
data coming in and more
and more requests coming in.
And there are two sides
here on the scaling issue,
one on the Hadoop side
and the Netezza side.
The Hadoop side, although
relatively easily,
we could scale it buying
machine and storage.
The business was unpredictable.
It was very hard to predict
what was going on tomorrow,
next week, next year.
And so we were
struggling and compromise
between CPU and storage
constantly and, of course,
spending time keeping
the costs down.
On the Netezza side was
much, much harder to scale.
You just have to double
up on the cluster.
And we're talking about millions
of dollars of investment.
Needless to say that that
data warehouse team, instead
of being an enabler
to the organization,
not because of their fault, was
actually a disabling factor.
And the reason was
80% of their time
was spent maintaining
infrastructure, maintaining
the cluster and making sure
the existing pipeline wouldn't
break.
So long story short, late
2013, beginning in 2014,
we started looking
at alternatives.
We did a bunch of
POCs and BigQuery
was the big winner
for us by far.
We moved every single
piece of data into it.
We never looked back.
It was the best
decision we ever made.
The reason we picked
BigQuery is twofold.
Number one, it is a
serverless infrastructure,
meaning it is a service to us.
We don't need to
worry about scaling.
worry about tuning.
The second big reason is
you could query hundreds
of terabytes of data
within seconds and minutes
versus before it
would have taken
hours and days if the query
ever came back to start with.
So how does the
architecture look like now
that we have BigQuery?
Very much simplified
compared to before.
Still we have a
custom Ingest problem
that pushed the raw
level data into BigQuery.
The data warehouse ecosystem
right now it's only BigQuery.
Every single piece of
data is inside BigQuery.
The data warehouse team
will process the data
by leveraging all the API
available from BigQuery
to process and produce
the same [INAUDIBLE]..
We used to produce before and
we're pushed into BigQuery.
And the way the business would
access data was through Tableau
pointed to BigQuery
at this time.
And then another
thing that we did,
we gave access to the user
using BigQuery native UI.
By giving access
to role level data
to a bunch of people
with SQL knowledge,
what happened is the
amount of requests that
came through the data warehouse
team and the engineering
teams skyrocketed, because
all of these people
finally saw the richness
of the data that we had.
And they never had access to it.
All of a sudden they
started dreaming
about these data products,
all of this stuff
they wanted to build.
And long story short,
we remove completely
the bottleneck of our
infrastructure with BigQuery.
But then a new
bottleneck was created,
which was engineer
resources, because we
had this unbelievable
racecar, which was BigQuery
and only a few people could
drive it to its potential.
And those were people
with engineering skills.
That's when we decided to
build a couple of tools, Magnus
and Gliath, with the goal of
empowering as many people as
possible within the organization
to basically be a data
engineer like anybody else
with engineering skills
but without of course,
just with secret knowledge.
They could do
everything on their own
without involving anybody else.
And that's where Magnus and
Goliath were born in 2015
and now available on Google
Marketplace as of 2018.
I'm going to give
you a quick demo.
But before I do that,
the new architecture
looks very similar than before.
There are two main differences.
Number one, Potens.io
tools on top of BigQuery
are now used for processing
and accessing the data.
Another big difference, a little
subtle here, you don't see it.
But if you remember
previous two diagram,
there was this gray
box data warehouse.
That's gone.
And the reason it's gone
is because two-fold,
the data warehouse engineers,
first of all, their job
description has changed.
And now our software engineer
building the Potens tool.
This team is not servicing the
organization in terms of data
needs anymore.
Second is we actually fully
decentralized our data
warehouse.
And there is no central
point where requests come in.
Everybody can do
everything they want
around data as long as
they have permission
on a specific data set.
And now I'm going to jump into
the demo, demo number one.
On this demo, right
now, I am an analyst.
I work for the
client services team.
And my clients, the DSP
clients, are the advertisers.
These advertisers have been
asking to get their data back
on a daily basis or whatever,
basically their impression
logs back.
And the reason is they
use multiple platforms
and want to aggregate
everything in one place.
And for that, I
decided to use Magnus
because I'm very familiar
with Magnus, which
is our workflow automator.
And I want to make it
such a way that it's
generic such that I can use--
if a new client
comes in tomorrow
and wants the same
thing, I shouldn't
be able to change anything.
And the workflows adjust fine.
Before I jump into the
automation part of it,
I want to show you what
the data set looks like.
And for that, I
am using Goliath,
which is our data
explorer, the tool that you
use to explore your data
sets, be able to query,
interact with data.
Specifically, I'm going to--
the data set I'm talking about
is ad impression data set.
This is an actual
sample of actual data.
So we're talking about 28
terabytes of data right,
4.3 billion rows in total.
You can see quickly,
double-clicking,
you have a sense of
all the tables in here.
I can sort.
I can see the size of each
specific table, the size.
And then if I click
on it, I can see
that Goliath does
a very nice job
on grouping logically the
data by year, month, and day.
I can mouse over a specific day.
I see exactly what the
size of this table.
If I click, I can see
the scheme of my table.
And like I mentioned before,
we have this more than 700 data
points per single event.
An impression is an event.
And I can show you here
if I expand my list,
you can see that we
have all this in here.
Those are basically all
columns in our table.
And for us was very important
to see that organized the way
we actually saw the data, which
is objects, within objects.
Another thing that
was important for us
as well is to actually
see what the content looks
like for anyone that is trying
to work on queries on the data.
So we wanted to represent
the data as objects
as well, the moment you
preview or you query the data.
As you can see, I can go across
my columns and see the content
and have quickly a glance
of what each single field
value could be like.
And specifically,
now, since I'm going
to be talking about extracting
log from the impression tables,
one important field
I'm going to be needing
is the advertiser
ID, which is the one
I'm going to apply the
filter for that query.
And since I said I want to make
this thing very generic, what
I'm doing is creating a table
called advertiser_to_extract.
And this advertiser_to_extract
has two columns.
Number one is telling
me all the advertiser
ID they need the data bank,
which is the first column.
The second column is
telling me, well, definitely
all advertisers, they don't
want the surrounding data
points that we have.
They just want to
pick and choose
whatever fields they
want from the table.
And here, I'm describing
what they are.
And now I'm going
to jump into Magnus,
which is how I'm going
to create this workflow
to automate this extraction.
So the first workflow is
called parallel_extract.
And before jumping into
specifics of the workflow,
you can see on the top
the name of the workflow,
the description, the owner.
I can set up a
lifetime of a workflow.
And more importantly, I can
schedule it as a cron, fixed,
or advanced as a cron job.
And then you can specify
a time zone as well
for this specific workflow.
On the right, you'll see
very important element here,
which are what we
call parameters.
And parameters are two
kind, built-in and custom.
Built-in is things that the
system generates for you,
Magnus generate for you, are
typically time and date-based.
And custom is anything
you want to create.
Think about variable
and constant
in your programming language.
They're used to make
your content dynamic
and create business
knowledge around it.
I'm going to show you how
I use these parameters.
So the first task I'm using
right now-- by the way,
you can create several task.
And you put them sequentially.
And that describes the workflow.
My first task is a loop task.
As a loop task, it
requires an input table.
This table, I'm referencing
it via this variable.
And this variable is the
table I just show you before,
which was a two
Potens, which is one
that describes the advertiser
at the end and field.
And then it needs
a parameter, which
is called, in this
case, advertiser,
which is going to iterate
over and pull a row per table.
Every time I take this table,
I'm going to pull a row.
And this variable
is of type record.
And you can see here
the way it looks.
It's basically the scheme
of the table, advertiserid,
and the string
which is the field.
Another thing
inside this loop, I
have only one task,
which is a BigQuery task.
And what this thing does
is just running a query.
But as you can see, there
are dynamic elements
inside the query, which
is the table itself I'm
going to extract the data from.
I'm using this variable.
Then the filter itself,
which is the first element
of the record, which
represent the advertiserid.
And this is the
fields that I need out
of this specific query.
And then another
thing I wanted to do
is make the output
of the table generic.
I want to post fix the
tables with the advertiserid
and the data I'm
processing with.
Another thing that was very
important for my client
is to get the data
as soon as possible.
So what I wanted to do is--
typically, you have a workflow
that runs sequentially.
And sequentially
because a specific task
depends on the previous task.
Well, in this specific
case, I really
don't need things sequential
because every single query is
independent of each other.
Through macros, I can
check, simply say,
run this asynchronously and make
them all run at the same time
to maximize time.
And then at the end
of the loop task,
it just simply wait for
all of them to finish.
I can set up a time out.
I can get a notification in
case there was any error.
So now I'm going to run this
query, this workflow by hand.
And the output of these
tables will show up
inside this data set.
Right now, it's still be empty.
And while this
workflow is running,
I want to show you how you
actually check what's going on.
You look at the workflow
setting, specifically
for this workflow, you can
see it is still running.
The previous execution
actually finished,
So I'm clicking on this one.
And you can see that the 10
iterations got submitted.
The loop task finished
in 14 seconds.
All 10 queries got submitted.
I can drill down on
any query and see
what was the query
that got submitted.
You see the macros
got expanded for me.
You can see as well how my state
is scanning the specific query.
And you can check every
single one of them.
And then at the end, you
see there is the wait task.
It's waiting for all
of them to finish.
And let's see if
now it's finished.
It's not finished yet.
But the tables start
showing up here.
And actually, all of
them are finished now.
You can see the 10
advertiser are all done.
And if I click on here to see
if it did what it was supposed
to do, well, for
advertiser 3312,
you need an xid time
stamp request URL.
And [INAUDIBLE] all
of them work properly.
One thing I want to
point out, OK, I'm
done with this specific demo.
But one thing is
it was relatively
simple to build with Magnus.
Just three steps,
really, three tasks.
But if I had to do
this outside of Magnus,
I would have needed
to ask an engineer
to build this software around
it, create a bunch of threads,
push a bunch of jobs
out, wait for them
to finish in another
thread, and then
ask system engineers
to have a machine
to run this thing
on a cron job, worry
about all this monitoring.
All of that, it is
completely gone with Magnus.
We don't need to worry
about any of that.
It's just managed
transparently, it's
a service on top of a
service, which is BigQuery.
So next example,
next example is going
to be a little more
sophisticated example.
In this case, I want to showcase
how you can connect Magnus
with other system
via an API task
because Magnus can be initiated
via manually or through a cron
job.
It can be called the API.
We can trigger an
execution on Magnus
with a bunch of GCP events.
But how do you connect
Magnus with external system,
let's say with other GCP
API or your internal API?
Well, we have an API task.
Of course, with the API task the
world of opportunity opens up.
And specifically, now,
I am a product manager.
I work for the DSP.
And I have-- my advertisers
have been telling me lately
that it takes too long
for my images creatives
to be approved.
And the reason it
takes too long is
because we have humans
involved that check physically
if the image violates
our content policy.
And as a product manager
I have the idea, well,
I know how to improve this.
I would like to have my
engineers build this thing.
But engineers are always busy.
So I decided to
take it on my own.
And the reason I decided
to take it on my own
because I'm familiar
with Magnus.
And also I see that Magnus
has this API task and a bunch
of templates that available to
make it very easy to connect
to any API from
the GCP ecosystem,
including Dataflow, Pub/Sub,
Google Cloud Storage, machine
learning-- which I'm going
to show you right now
et cetera-- so it's
very, very easy.
And you don't need to worry
about rejection authentication
because the token gets passed
automatically by Magnus.
So at that point, I
decide, OK, it's cool.
I can do it.
I did some research
on Google Vision API.
And I see they have
a specific API which
is exactly what I need,
which is annotation
API with a safe search
detection type of annotation
that takes in input an
image, and gives me back
if the image contains adult
content, violent content,
racist content, medical content.
It's exactly what I need.
So what I'm going to do is just
build this Magnus workflow,
which is
annotate_new_creatives_demo.
Since it's a little more complex
compared to the previous one,
I'm going to give you
a view because one
of the task, for
instance, I am using here
is calling a workflow.
So you can modularize your code
and create a bunch of tasks
within a workflow and then
make other people use it.
This case, to show
you the entire view
of what's going on here,
I'm showing you the preview.
At 1,000 feet level, these
are the name of the task.
You can drill in on
each one of them.
So what this process
will do is just check
if on the creative
table there are
any new creatives being pushed.
If there are any
new creative, I'm
going to call the
classify_ads workflow.
If not, I'm done.
There is no new
creative to process.
So I've finished.
The classify_ads
workflow, what it does
is loops in batch and batches
the creative in input just
to make sure I don't want
to call one at a time.
I just want to batch as
many as the API allows me.
And then creates the payload
with this generate_payload.
In basically, the API
requires a JSON payload,
I'm using BigQuery to
create this payload,
pass it to the API task, and
then take the result back.
And on the calling
workflow, I'm checking here
if there was any creative
that got flagged.
If there were any
creative that got flagged,
I send an email out.
So I'm going to execute this.
And I should be receiving
an email shortly.
But while this
thing is executing,
I'm going to give you a little
more insight into the workflow.
So the first workflow is
what I just described before.
I'm checking if there are
any new creatives to process.
And the way I'm doing this
is by leveraging the fact
that parameters are actually
persisted for Magnus.
So I'm using the result
of the previous execution
to check what was my last
ID that got processed.
And then I'm just using it
as a parameter on this query,
take every new creative
since the last creative ID,
take the output and
put it on this table.
This table is described
here, creatives_input.
Then what I do is count
the number of rows
out of this query,
which is specifically
count the rows on this
table and assign it
to this variable,
which is new_rows.
And then if this is
the if/then condition,
I check if there
are any new rows.
If it's greater then zero pretty
much, go to the next task,
otherwise finish because
they have nothing else to do.
The next-- by the way, this
flashing means workflow
finished.
I'll show you the email soon.
The next workflow,
which actually
does the job of
classifying the ads,
is this classify_ads workflow.
Workflow take inputs
and those basically
are the parameters for
the workflow, which
is the destination table
where this annotation need
to be stored.
The source table,
the input to my API
without all this
creative, I need to check.
The batch size as well
as the type of annotation
that I need to call the
Google Vision API with.
And then I'm basically storing
my ID for the next iteration
so I remember where
to start next time.
And here I'm checking
if any creative
got flagged with a SQL query.
Let me go back here.
And I should have
received the email.
OK, there's a new email
that just got sent.
As you can see, it's
basically an HTML table
with the first HDID
of the creatives.
The second is the image
that got annotated.
And as you can see
here, these three images
have medical annotation
type of-- there's
a possibility there is medical
content inside this image.
And the same thing
for all three of them.
So it worked, meaning
it's able to detect
there were three creative,
possible medical content.
By the way, for the
purpose of the demo,
I just disable the check
across adult content
and that's just to avoid showing
something on the screen that
was not appropriate.
As you can see here, you see
the lines I commented out?
And this is just
running the query.
It's generating my
little HTML table
that I'm sending via email here.
And here, the email task, I'm
simply say, OK, format as HTML.
This is the editor of the table.
And these are the
three rows you just
saw with this variable, which
is being computed by this query.
And now I'm going to show
you by clicking here what
exactly those query returned.
If I run this query,
you'll see that the three
rows were this ones.
Means basically, I'm showing
an image in the content.
And as you can see,
this query shouldn't
run because that is
variables in here.
But guess what?
When I click from Magnus
and jump into Goliath,
all parameters that I need to
be able to execute the query
are being brought over.
And I can show you the used
ones for the specific query
were those ones.
So I am able to debug
specific query the way
they are without changing them.
So say that, I want
to show you how
I generate the payload from the
classify_ads internal workflow.
This is the execution
of the classify_ads.
So I was batching the creative.
Basically, I'm using the limit
and the offset of the creative
to batch through a
bunch of creatives.
And then, I'm
basically generating
the payload via a query.
You'll see what this query is.
This query is a--
I mean, it looks complicated,
but it's basically
I'm generating a JSON object
out of three rows on a table.
And I can cut and paste
this so you'll see what
the output of this query is.
This is the output
of this table.
It's basically a payload
for my API, which is a JSON
representation of the images.
And then if I look here, the
next task that got executed
is the call of the
annotation API.
What I passed in
input is this JSON
that I prepare with
the previous queries.
And that's the output back.
So for each query, it's
telling me the probability
of each type of content.
And then the next task, I'm
using JavaScript task to--
it's out of sync, sorry--
to populate the table itself
and take the result back.
So this, again, is to showcase
a little more complex use
case to be able to
connect with several APIs.
But you can have
microservices internal to you.
And you can do a similar thing.
One thing I want to
show you is now--
can you bring it back to
the presentation please?
To the slides?
Yes.
How do we use--
what are the stats of
Potens within Viant?
Viant is not the only customer.
Viant built Potens.
But we have multiple
customers of Potens.
Those are stats only
within Viant itself.
Field today, we have about
360 user using the platform.
And by the way, we don't
have that many engineers.
It's all BI team,
research analytic team.
They're product people, anyone
you can imagine using the tool.
Those people generated
5,000 workflow.
Total number of tasks across
all workflow is 180,000.
You can see somebody went
crazy and built a workflow
with 3,200 tasks in it.
So it must have been
something complex.
But the average is about 36.
Probably the median is
much smaller than that.
And then this is the current
month, the way Potens is used.
130 users use Magnus.
Those 130 user generated
600,000 workflow executions.
These workflow execution
generate 2 queries in BigQuery.
And these 2 million query
process 16 petabytes of data.
That's on a normal month.
It was last month.
If you're wondering how
tasks are used within Magnus,
well, BigQuery, to no
surprise, is the favorite task
because that's the
workhorse where
all the things are happening.
The big data crunching is
happening through BigQuery.
The next most popular
task is GOTO task.
It does make sense because you
do business logic through that,
if/then/else conditions.
The workflow tasks is
very much used as well.
That's because you want a
modularize your workflows.
You can have people
build something
a little more complex like, for
instance, this classify_ads.
And you, as a user,
you can leverage it
by calling it as a library.
Then the API task is just to
connect with other systems.
And then the script
has to manipulate data
in the email, although
is a small percent.
But it's very much used.
But, of course, you have one
email probably per workflow.
So that's why it's only 1%.
And that's it for
the presentation.
Just go ahead and try Potens.io.
You're going to get
unlimited use of Goliath
and a trial of Magnus.
We love it.
Our customers love it.
And it changed our life.
Before we had a
handful of people
be able to do complex
things with data.
Now you have hundreds of
people within our organization
that can do as much as data
engineers or data warehouse
engineers could do
without involving people
with engineering skills.
Thank you.
Have a good one.
Give back to Mehran.
MEHRAN NAZIR: Thank
you, Fabrizio.
A round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
That was a live demo.
I was actually watching him.
He did hit Refresh
button a couple times.
My heart was racing.
That was probably the
most exciting thing
I'll see at a Cloud conference.
[LAUGHTER]
But with that, I
wanted to highlight--
if it were Fabrizio
speaking, he wanted
to highlight three big
things that Viant did
in this particular scenario.
One, in the first
slide, they showed
that they had a very, very
extended cloud footprint.
And they said, we no longer
want to manage infrastructure.
That was the first step, no
longer manage that headache.
Two, they created
an interface to make
data accessible to their
entire organization.
One of the more powerful
insights from that presentation
was that it no longer
belonged to data scientists.
It belonged to business users.
It belonged to all
kinds of people
that no longer needed to work
with the data scientists.
And then, three, they're able
to extend the power of BigQuery
with the rest of the
Google Cloud Platform.
The most powerful thing
about that second demo
was that it was now
using the machine
learning APIs to basically
generate metadata
to associate with creatives.
Instead of having to create a
completely different workflow
in a completely different
application for customers
to access another part of
the Google Cloud ecosystem,
this particular tool they built
was built all on top of that.
And when I've seen
successful data companies,
it's companies that really bring
the power of different cloud
technologies all
together in one place.
So to summarize,
BigQuery doesn't
have to be exclusively
used by your data teams.
Again, to think
that it is as only
the domain of data scientists
would be very short-sighted.
The real power is
when you unlock
that power for the rest
of the organization.
You create tools like Magnus
or build your own tools,
work with other partners.
And then lastly, BigQuery
is a flexible and extensible
platform, one that allows
you to basically take
its compute power and apply it
in many different scenarios.
I don't know if you guys
were paying attention
to the specific numbers
that were being generated,
but in the first demo,
I saw that one iteration
was going through 300 gigabytes
within 10, 15 seconds.
And there was 10 queries
being run in parallel.
That's about 3 terabytes.
And again, that data--
that processing time
doesn't scale linearly.
It goes exponentially faster.
And that is a very
powerful insight
to take away, to help
BigQuery to become the center
point of your
data-driven organization.
To summarize, I want to also
just kind of point you guys
to other really
interesting presentations.
We have a number of customers.
They'll be presenting
their stories with BigQuery
and showing how they
use the power of it
to enable their organizations.
But a special focus
on the top line,
give a SPOTLIGHT session at
2:10, tomorrow afternoon.
This is where we
will be announcing
all of the new magics
with BigQuery and also
across all our entire
Google Analytics platform,
from Dataflow to Pub/Sub
to other new products
that we'll be announcing.
I'm not allowed to say
anything about it today
or all of a sudden I'm
going to lose my job.
But I would like
you guys to-- invite
you guys to see that tomorrow.
[MUSIC PLAYING]